[Applause]
foreign thank you so much Heather and
it's great to be back in Munich and uh
great to be here together with uh Matt
and uh and Maya and I look forward to
our conversation in just a few moments
Russia's war against Ukraine grinds on
we may be shocked by its brutality but
we should not be surprised
this is this is part of a pattern of
Russian aggression for several years
and NATO allies shared precise
intelligence about moscow's plans for
the invasion long in advance
over many months we made every effort to
engage Russia in diplomacy
and just days before on this very stage
in Munich I called on President Putin to
step back from the brink
but despite our calls for peace he chose
to attack
we can already draw some important
lessons from the war
first we must sustain and step up our
support to Ukraine
Putin is not planning for peace
he is planning for more war new offenses
and there are no indications he has
changed his ambitions
he is mobilizing hundreds of thousands
of troops
increasingly putting the Russian economy
on a war footing
and reaching out to other authoritarian
regimes such as Iran and North Korea to
get more weapons
so we must give Ukraine what they need
to win and Prevail as a sovereign
independent nation in Europe
some worry that
that our support to Ukraine risks
triggering escalation
let me be clear
there are no risk-free options
but the biggest risk of all is if Putin
wins
Putin wins in Ukraine the message to him
and other authoritarian leaders will be
that they can use Force to get what they
want
this will be the world more dangerous
and us more vulnerable
so supporting Ukraine
is not only the morally right thing to
do
it is also in our own security interest
the second lesson is that we need to
continue to strengthen our attorneys on
defense
Wars are unpredictable and we do not
know when or how this one will end
but I do know this even if the war ends
tomorrow our security environment has
changed for the long term
there is no going back
Kremlin wants a different Europe
Russia controls Neighbors
we also know
that Beijing is watching closely
to see the price Russia pays
or the reward he receives for its
aggression
what is happening in Europe today could
happen in Asia tomorrow
so the war in Ukraine demonstrates that
security is not Regional it is global
in this new and more contested world we
can no longer afford to treat defense as
optional it is a necessity
yes spending more on defense means less
money for other important tasks
but nothing is more important than our
security to preserve peace
the third lesson
is that we need to strengthen the
resilience of our societies
military forces are necessary to protect
our security
but they are not sufficient
we must also secure our cyberspace
our supply chains and our infrastructure
the war in Ukraine has made clear
the danger of over-reliance on
authoritarian regimes
not so long ago many argued that
importing Russian gas was purely an
economic issue
it is not
it is a political issue it is about our
security
because Europe's dependency on Russian
gas made us vulnerable
so we should not make the same mistakes
with China and other authoritarian
regimes
we must not become too dependent on
products and raw materials we import
avoid exporting key technologies that
could be used against us and protect our
critical infrastructure at home
of course we should continue to trade
and engage economically with China
but our economies and our economic
interests cannot outweigh our security
interests
so it's only right that we protect
ourselves
but in doing so
we must remember that trade among
friends and allies makes us stronger and
more resilient
we must not create new barriers between
free and open economies
the most important lesson
from the war in Ukraine is that North
America and Europe must stand together
in a more dangerous world we need our
transatlantic Alliance more than ever
without NATO there is no security in
Europe
so this is not the time
to look beyond the alliance
this is the time to strengthen and
enlarge our alliance
to promote peace
protect our shared security and defend a
global system based on our values and
international law so thank you and then
I look forward to our conversation
[Applause]
secretary Secretary General stoltenberg
thank you and let me please welcome our
panelists to to the platform and and
while they're walking up
Secretary General if I may start with
you okay well we'll do the handshake
first here
thank you welcome
Secretary General everyone's getting
seated if I may just ask you the first
question
and I want to pull on your
the unthinkable but if Putin wins as you
suggested that
NATO would have to incredibly strengthen
the Eastern flank it's NATO spending two
percent would be the absolute floor
how do we as an alliance prepare for the
unthinkable and what does that Alliance
look like for the next 10 15 20 years
the first of all President Putin must
not win this war and that's why NATO
allies importance all around the world
has mobilized so much support to to
Ukraine because it will be a tragedy for
the ukrainians but it will also be
extremely dangerous for us because then
the message is that when he uses Force
then he gets what he he wants and we
need to understand this this is not only
a European challenge this is a global
challenge I I recently visited South
Korea and and Japan two close supporters
of NATO and they see the link between
what's going on in Europe and what's
going on and may happen in Asia so
Beijing is watching closely the outcome
of the war in Ukraine and of course if
Putin wins in Ukraine it will impact the
decisions and the calculations that
Beijing is doing in their part of the
world so this is about our Global
Security this is not about Regional
security
NATO has already adapted the war didn't
start in February last year it started
in 2014 and since 2014 we have
implemented the biggest reinforcement of
collective defense with more troops High
redness presence in eastern part of the
Lions new defense bans and also
increased defense spending and when we
meet in billions this year I'm
absolutely certain not we will as a
reconfirm that message both the stronger
partnership with our partners in the
Asia Pacific support for Ukraine but
also how to strengthen our turns and
defense Secretary General I want one
more question to you and then I want to
bring our other panelists into the
conversation so in five months the
Allies will gather in vilness an
incredibly important Summit at the end
of that Summit what does success look
like for you and for the alliance well
the success is about demonstrating
the the unwavering support for Ukraine
and I'm absolutely confident that that
will confident that that will be the
case in real news it's about uh
the reiterating our commitment to
strengthen the Returns on defense and
it's about building the partnership with
our asia-pacific partners because
security is not Regional security is
global but then there is one other thing
that will Mark success and that is that
we will enlarge the alliance
I really
work hard and and really hope that by
the win the summit we will have
finalized the accession process and we
have Finland and Sweden as the two new
members of our Airlines
way to opening our conversation with
president nunusu but before I get to the
accession question president needs to
other than former Chancellor Miracle you
probably have had the most conversations
with Vladimir Putin and it was important
to keep that dialogue I would imagine
your last conversation was when you
shared with him that Finland was
applying for a NATO membership but I
want to ask you because your knowledge
of Vladimir Putin and you've observed
his leadership over the last 12 months
help us understand where you think this
regime is going it's been under enormous
stress and I you have some of the
sharpest analytical thinking about
Russia and then I'm going to ask you
that accession question but I want to
start there first okay thank you
I have heard said that the Russian
regime
is the same in the future if not even
more of the same and we know what the
same is here so we haven't seen any
major changes except that maybe the
leadership is more concentrated on Putin
and the amount of elite people around
him is maybe reducing a bit those more
from the business side are maybe far
further away at the moment
we have to keep in mind that
military is number one in Russian
Society in their economy in their
industry whatever and
I guess that they are measuring this
situation all the time the Ukrainian War
by their military success and that's the
only figure that really
that they really care about and that
also explains that what is going on and
I'm afraid we'll continue
so something like this
more of the same greater intensity which
moves us to the urgency of Finland and
Sweden
formally joining the alliance so and
Secretary General I may be bringing you
into this conversation as well because I
want to make sure I understand where we
are in the process
um you were just in Ankara visiting uh
with the senior Turkish officials
obviously the devastation of the
earthquake is is unimaginable
but we now have this challenge of a
timeline to get to the Vilnius Summit so
you were very clear Secretary General
and Ankara saying both Sweden Finland
are ready
but and we want them to enter as soon as
possible
but this suggests that as our Turkish
colleagues have suggested that they will
they are ready to approve Finland to
enter Finnish Parliament is making the
preparations to do that President I just
I need the clarity we know we want
Finland and Sweden to come together
that's the goal but if we must and if
turkey and of course Hungary
approves the accession ratifies the
accession protocols only for Finland
would Finland walk through that door by
itself and if so Secretary General what
are the implications for that scenario
okay our position is crystal clear
we with Sweden we have made an
application expressing our will to join
NATO and that wheel is
considered by member states 28 of them
have accepted us
then
to Turkey
turkey
it's in their hands
we have got messages and you have to be
quite Keen when you hear messages from
Turkey they may change every now and
then but nevertheless we have heard them
saying also that in an increasing way
that Finland yes Finland meets criterias
which they have put which are a bit
different from those criterias of NATO
but little by little they have increased
in expressing that they might ratify
Finland and just Finland
and even we have heard some voices that
if Finland is willing to this kind of
separation and our answer is very clear
we have expressed our will together with
Sweden and we don't react
at all we will not uh
accept or demand any kind of Separation
but still situation is such that
our applications are at the
table in Ankara and if Turkey decides
that yes they will answer yes to Finland
but not yet yes to Sweden
well that would be quite a
quite a difficult situation our hands
are in a way tight we have applied for
membership should we now say that no we
cancel our application no that we can't
simply do so
that's how it looks like but I want to
assure that
we we have done our part by applying
applying together with the Sweden that's
our will to become a member and it's in
Turkish and to decide whether they want
to have us
Secretary General it is a dilemma and I
think you've done an excellent job of
trying to manage that we want them both
in but we may anticipate a pacing issue
here how do we continue to provide that
strong message of solidarity and
security particularly as we get closer
to the wellness Summit first of all NATO
has made the decisions we need to make
as the alliance already we made an
historic decision at our Summit in July
to invite Finland and Sweden to become
members and then we all made the
decision uh to agree the accession
protocols and all allies have signed
accession protocols so the NATO
decisions have been made
what now remains is the ratification
process of those protocols in all the 30
Allied countries so far 28 out of 30
have already ratified and then a turkey
and and Hungary remains of course my
message has been and it was also my
message Ankara earlier this week that
both Finland and Sweden are ready for
ratification they have met their
obligations they signed with the
territoral memorandum with turkey NATO
Summit last July and therefore I urge
all allies to finalize the ratification
but I also said that of course what
matters is that both becomes become
members as soon as possible
not whether one become a member before
the other the most important is to get
them both in as soon as possible and I
continue to work hard to ensure that
they are members by the villain Summit
if I can just add one more thing and
that is that this means that it is a
Turkish decision
because they have two protocols and and
I urge the turkey to ratify both
but of course if the rat if I won then
then then Finland will be a member of
the uh the alliance
um
point is that we have to remember that
Sweden Anthony very much better place
now than before they applied it's not as
if nothing has happened they are now
invitees meaning that they're sitting at
the NATO table they participate in NATO
meetings they're more and more
integrated in NATO military structures
defense planning civilian and Military
activities NATO has increased its
presence in the area
allies United States and many others
have issued assurances security
Assurance as part of the accession
process so it's inconceivable that there
will be any military threat against
Finland or Sweden without NATO reacting
so yes we need to find us the process
that will come a very long way already
both with Finland and Sweden thank you
thank you to you both this is essential
and as we understand uh the next several
weeks and months so thank you president
Sandu
all leaders have tough weeks but I think
you've had a particularly tough week and
I I want you to help us understand of
course hearing news reports that
intelligence had picked up a Russian
malign operation in Moldova it to me
sounded very similar to 2016 in
Montenegro to be honest with you that
type of disruption if you could share
with us what you can sort of your
understanding you mentioned earlier this
week that the Situation's still highly
destabilizing
and after you share that how can we
learn to better protect our societies
from Russian malign influence
Moldova is certainly under enormous
pressure right now so welcome your
thoughts on that and then I turn to how
we can strengthen NATO's partnership
with Moldova in these difficult days
please
thank you first I would like to say that
Russia's war against Ukraine has
enormous repercussions on every aspect
of model of security
it increased including the military risk
for Moldova in the last few months we
saw four missiles
Crossing illegally our airspace
we have many cases of Rocket debris
falling on our territory we see threats
coming from different representatives of
Russia the recent one from the Minister
of Foreign Affairs who indicated that
Moldova might be the next in line but as
long as Ukraine keeps the Russian army
far from our borders we believe that
there is not an imminent military threat
to Moldova and Ukraine keeps us safe at
the same time Russia is already waging a
hybrid war against Moldova and we have
many examples in the fall they try to
use the energy crisis hoping that will
not be able to pay for the very high
prices for gas and electricity when they
saw that the government managed to find
the money that's from Cut gas supply by
60 hoping that we will not find
alternative sources and that the paid
protests will overthrow the elected the
legally elected governments
now we've learned about a new plan that
they might bring they might try to bring
people from outside the country to
organize these violent protests and then
to force the authorities into
negotiations on Snap parliamentary
elections there are many elements of
these hybrid war of course the most
damaging to our democracy is propaganda
and the disinformation but there are
multiple cyber attacks there are
and of course all of this is meant to
destabilize the society and to use the
difficult economic situation that we
face because of of Russia's war in
Ukraine to to bring people into the
streets and then to to change the
government and to bring the pro-essian
government that it could use also
against Ukraine
thank you president Sandu Moldova has
had a long-standing partnership with
NATO there's now a NATO liaison office
uh in Kiza now
as we think about building and
strengthening our partnership what are
opportunities and ways that NATO can be
more impactful and helping Moldova with
security sector reform strengthening and
modernizing your defense structures give
us some ideas as as we continue to
strengthen European security indeed we
do have a long-standing partnership with
NATO and we are very grateful and we are
very committed to our long-term plans at
the same time we did get or the promise
for additional support at the Madrid
Summit thank you for that the priority
now is to have
projects with immediate impact and the
biggest problem that we have now is the
need for air surveillance and defense
and this is needed for Moldova but this
is also needed for the entire region so
we would like our partners to consider
this type of assistance that we urgently
needs because of the internal threats of
the hybrid where we also need to support
to develop our strategic intelligence
capabilities
to deal with the Cyber threats we need
support to modernize our border security
and control we need support for special
intervention Focus capabilities and I
believe we need to work together and to
be more efficient in tackling the
Russian propaganda it's extremely
difficult for us to tackle this issue
alone I think we need to have common
approaches on fighting the
disinformation the pro-war propaganda I
think we need to have common approaches
in dealing with the social networks
which are not responsive to moldova's
requests when it comes to the pro-war
propaganda and to the designation and I
do believe that they can take because
seriously when we approach them together
but this is a very big issue and as I
said the propaganda that this
information is probably now the most
damaging element for our society and for
our democracy well and your moldova's
very much a laboratory right now of that
propaganda so the alliance could learn
an enormous amount prime minister
frequency
um as as you've now uh re-election has
happened you've had an extraordinary
year of leadership I would say Denmark
has had its own zeiten vendor when you
after the The War Began The full-scale
Invasion Denmark taking the important
step of joining the common security
defense policy of the EU committing a
billion in defense spending
what more needs to be done and I think
the one concern that I have as we get
closer to the NATO Summit is we are one
year away from seeing how NATO members
have fulfilled their Wales pledge of
meeting two percent in 2024. we know
Denmark will be shy of that despite the
increase in spending help us understand
the leadership role that you've taken
through this period and and how Denmark
is is increasing its defense spending in
this regard
can I first of all say that Maya you are
really a brave European president
I mean
Moldova is a small it's a pool and it's
a fragile European country
you can be next in line
when we're talking about Russia
and you are standing up you as a person
for democracy rule of law and
anti-corruption
so you are a brave European leader and
of course all our awareness is about
Ukraine I totally agree with you yes we
have to do more and we have to do it
faster
but at the same time let us not forget
Moldova
Georgia
and and uh and other neighboring
countries so when you ask me what are
the next thing to do
we have to and we need to spend more on
our defense
of course that's number one we have to
do as much as we can to support Ukraine
with weapons more donations and we have
to do it faster
I think we have to work more closely
together in Europe
to keep up producing
because
it is extremely important to donate more
and to do it faster but also to be able
to defend ourselves to defend ourselves
but we also have to build much stronger
Partnerships and of course Moldova is is
a great example of this but also when it
comes to the global South
because we focus on Ukraine that is
extremely important but at the same time
I mean what is going on in Africa what's
going on in this hell region
and if we are not able as European
countries to build strong alliances in
Asia of course transatlantic is where it
it starts and where it begins and where
it ends I totally agree but if we are
not able to build stronger alliances
with India with our Palace in in Asia as
you said yes in Africa in other places
of the world we will lose I think the
global war on values
so we have to do a lot of things at the
same time and we have to I think be
aware that all the crisis we are facing
are interfering with each other
so uh of course being able to help
Ukraine and we have to win this one they
will never be able to win it on their
own we have to win it with them
we have to build a stronger European
Union we have to build stronger
Partnerships with our neighbors but we
have to be much more active on the
global scene at the same time
that's an extraordinary to-do list I
think one of my favorite quotes from you
right after the full-scale invasion was
historic times call for historical
decisions and I think that's what you're
talking about we this is what we've
talked about historical decisions about
Finland joining NATO historical
decisions about joining the
euro-atlantic community fully historic
decisions about defense spending prime
minister if I can ask you and take the
Liberty also of having president ninistu
here the Kingdom of Denmark plays an
extraordinary role geographically
because of its position in the North
Atlantic and the Kingdom of Denmark has
been Fair very forward-leaning on an
Arctic strategy understanding Russia's
Arctic
militarization and what that means I
know this is something that the
Secretary General often repeats which
we're very grateful for of course
finland's joint and Sweden joining NATO
has now the Arctic Council he's the
Arctic seven will now all will be NATO
members help us think in your own work
with the greenlanders where you see this
as far as building the alliance how we
build greater deterrence in the north
and how do we think about the high North
looking forward
yeah thank you for for bringing up the
high North I think it will be
um
uh for the next many years we will have
we we are in the need of having more
discussions about the high North
so we were talking about the hybrid
situation
um let's not forget about terrorism
uh the global situation when it comes to
terrorism it should still be on uh our
Common Table
um but I my guess is that we will see a
more fragile situation in the high North
as well
uh we are seeing more and more Russian
activities
and of course because of climate change
the high North will change
in many different aspects
so we need more awareness and we need to
to be physically
much more in the high North so
um
you were right the to-do list
is quite long and I have now made it
even longer
but that's how it is to be a leader in
these years I mean uh so so thank you
for for putting the high North and of
course
um Finland and and Sweden being NATO
members hopefully soon will also be very
important when when it comes to the
Arctic region and it is becoming more
and more fragile as well absolutely
president Mr you want to come in yes I
see two elements first the security both
of you I fully agree with the myth about
she she said
actually tradition has been the
authority Council doesn't take any
opinion on security issues and um well
we see at the same time that the high
North the tensions are growing all the
time and the interest towards that is
not only limited to Arctic
Council countries for example UK is
also strongly involved in security
issues but there's also another element
that that is
the environmental one we have to keep in
mind that Russia covers
half of the Arctic and I have often said
that if we lose the Arctic because of
climate change we lose the globe and
there we have to be capable of somehow
trying at least to to
cooperate or let Russians understand put
them understand
that the question is very crucial there
are houses are collapsing in in tundra
area where where the the
ice is melting so they have to realize
that it's a common problem too but back
to Securities use
that is an increasing issue and I
believe that NATO is taking more and
more notice to that too
so
it's a historic that we have two new
NATO members in Arctic Council in next
Arctic council meeting maybe I hope so
exactly so I'm going to bring the
audience into this important
conversation but I'm going to ask each
of you to help with a question that many
in the Think Tank Community are
wrestling with and I want a really short
answer I want to start with you I'm
going to work down the road so secretary
John I'm going to start with you do you
feel the center of gravity in Europe is
now shifted East and if you believe that
why
really short because we've had a debate
that no it's not shifting East yes it's
shifting East and then what does it mean
has it been shifting
it depends totally what do you mean by
the question what has shifted East is is
is NATO's presence also we have much
more presence military presence
exercises in these because we have seen
over several years uh a more aggressive
Russia and and and to respond to that
especially since 2014 we have for the
first in our history deployed uh NATO
troops in eastern part of Alliance but
of course many of those troops come from
the western part of the Lions so this
demonstrates how NATO is is is together
and how we support each other uh and uh
and and we do that to to ensure that uh
that Russia cannot continue uh it is
it's it's aggressive actions against
countries in Europe and and to send a
very clear message to Moscow that NATO
is there to protect and defend the NATO
territory every inso NATO territory
with Sweden and Finland do you feel that
sense of shift of gravity from the
war no I I agree with the ends of course
we need to be aware of the current
situation so so we have supported I mean
all the decisions that has been taken
when it comes to the Eastern flank and
probably we we will have to stay there
for a period of of time
um but I think what is so important
about nature is that
um NATO is flexible in its way of
thinking in our way of thinking
um so of course now the situation is
about Ukraine and uh
unfortunately maybe also other
neighboring countries but at the same
time we are able to work with the Cyber
hybrid situation
um and as I said before I think we need
more Focus if the South because of of
the very very difficult situation
especially in sahil region but
um I think the most important thing is
that we are flexible in our way of
thinking and we are able as NATO to move
very fast when something occurs in in
front of us
president Center do you feel that shift
to the east
I do believe that because of this war my
country is now already part of Europe's
security belt we have been helping with
refugees with the solidarity lanes and
we are trying to become a provider of
security we need help to become a more
serious provider of security for the
region president well I think it's quite
natural that we are now a bit eastwards
because of the Ukrainian War but I would
also point out a certain kind of
flexibility
surely we have to be prepared to react
wherever there's a problem and
North yes Arctic area Russian border yes
Black Sea maybe even Mediterranean so
to be ready to react to whatever that's
the lesson I guess we have got during
the past year so the
of gravity is flexibility and being
where we need to be all right we have
some great questions coming forward and
let me turn the microphone here right
down the front with Alexa
please introduce yourself and direct
your question to the panelists thank you
very much my name is Alexi gunsharenko
I'm a member of Ukrainian Parliament and
the topic of this panel is building the
aliens right and I think the building of
the airlines will be always incomplete
without Ukraine Moldova Georgia so I
have two questions from this first to
Secretary General stoltenberg this year
NATO Summit in Vilnius will there be a
strong and clear signal that Ukraine
will be member of NATO Maybe by
providing membership action plan or just
by statement but clear and strong that
NATO is weight in Ukraine and the second
question is to president Sandu maybe
it's the time for Moldova to revise the
policy of neutrality I understand that
it's not just your decision but I'm very
much interested in what you personally
think about it thank you very much thank
you Secretary General so NATO's position
on membership for your crane is
unchanged we agreed back in 2008 that
Ukraine will become a member of the
alliance and that is still our position
then of course what matters now is to
ensure that Ukraine prevails as a
sovereign independent state because
without having Ukraine as a certain
independent state there's no way to
discuss any kind of relationship between
A2 and Ukraine in the future so the
urgent need is to provide Military
Support as NATO allies and partners are
doing every day
in that context also welcome the the the
initiative from prime minister suno to
actually have a discussion about
the framework we need to ensure and an
enduring peace after this war ends
because when the war ends we need to
make sure that history doesn't repeat
itself that Russia doesn't continue to
invade Ukraine because this is a pattern
it started in 20 in 2008 the invasion of
of Georgia and then in 2014 Crimea and
donbos and then in in last year the
full-fledged invasion of Ukraine and we
cannot allow Russia to continue to Chip
Away
European security and we need to break
the circle of Russian aggression against
the European countries and and therefore
we need when this war ends to establish
some kind of framework that ensures that
Russia's aggression doesn't continue
president Sandra
Sandu um looking at what Russia does to
Ukraine today it's clear that neutrality
cannot defend us neutrality can defend
only when the other countries respect it
but you know that today there is no
popular support in our popular support
to change that and and we know that we
understand that and we acknowledge the
situation we can discuss why is that and
I think the Russian propaganda is to a
big extent to be blamed for that
for instance today the one of the lines
of the Russian propaganda is that
neutrality means that the country should
not strengthen its defense sector which
doesn't make any sense but unfortunately
there are many people in Moldova who are
scared of the war and they buy this kind
of propaganda so that's why I thought
that we need to to work together to
deal with this to counter this
propaganda but given the situation as I
said there is no question now about
changing the neutrality but definitely
Moldova should be helped to strengthen
its uh defense sector and Moldova should
be part of the new European security
architecture
thank you so much I see right back there
Tobias Elwood if we can have a
microphone right there if you can follow
my finger this will be the last question
because I have one closing question for
this panel Tobias uh thank you very much
indeed uh Secretary General I think you
summed up
the situation by saying Putin enjoys
using force and gets away with it and if
we don't stand up to Putin then he
exploits our weakness you've heard on
the stage the president of Moldova it
almost feels like we're going through
this all again
after Ukraine
could I ask what more we could do
internationally to support Moldova
because that could very much be next I
was one of the first people indeed at
this conference last year
to say that NATO countries or the joint
expeditionary Force
should be sending a forces
to Ukraine to prevent Russia's invasion
but we blinked we were spooked by
Russia's rhetoric
so my question is here you've heard from
the prime minister of Denmark as well
stating the difficulties that Moldova is
now facing yes of course we need to
pressurize and support Ukraine but
Moldova clearly could be next what more
can we do internationally what more can
NATO do what more can the joint
expeditionary Force do to support
Moldova now before it's too late prime
minister Ferguson I want to turn that
question to you as you always think what
can we do and then Secretary General if
you have some thoughts on that as well
should I start oh okay
um
I think Jens can answer when it comes to
what we can do in in the NATO frame but
I would like to add what we can do
politically
because what you said it's very
important that you have a big a big
minority
of your population that actually
supports Russia because of
fake news and and and and the war Russia
is is into when it comes to to the
Medias and and so on
and we can only as Leaders we can only
support you Crane and Moldova if we have
the support of our populations
because we are democracies
and when we are delivering like Denmark
our whole artillery to Ukraine it
demands support from our populations
so I think fighting inflation
working with Moldova when it comes to
energy you are not producing any energy
on your own
and I think you told me that the prices
of gas has been seven doubled
seven doubled
in a very very poor European country
so I mean if you are an ordinary family
in Moldova facing that your bills have
been seven doubles
you could maybe feel then it would be
better to have Russia to help us or to
be a part of our daily life
so I mean bringing Economic Development
into our partner countries and never to
forget the global South
I I really want wanted this perspective
because I mean the food crisis and the
energy crisis
is working against us when it comes to
the situation in in Ukraine so of course
there's something we can do when it
comes to protect Moldova
but at the same time we need to help to
develop Moldova
to to to make sure that the population
supports the European perspective both
when it comes to Nato and when it comes
to the European Union I think this is at
least as important as the heart
um missions that I guess we'll we'll
talk about as well
so first of all I agree uh fully with
meta we need to provide support on
different types of support to Moldova as
soon as possible
Georgia and Ukraine to other countries
which are vulnerable for Russian Russian
as they experience Russian aggression
they Aspire for NATO membership Moldova
has not made a decision to Aspire for
NATO membership and of course we totally
respect that but I think if there's any
lesson or an additional lesson to be
learned from the the war in Ukraine is
that we need to support countries which
are vulnerable for Russia and Russian
as fast and as soon as possible now
because the reality is that the main
reason why Ukraine has been able to to
repel and and to push back the Russian
forces is of course The Bravery the
courage of the Ukrainian armed forces
the political leadership the people of
Ukraine but one important element has
also been in the fact that NATO allies
actually trained and helped Ukraine
since 2014 the United Kingdom the United
States Canada and others provided
significant trading and capacity
building and also equipment from 2014
meaning that the Ukrainian Army much
were much stronger better equipped
better trained better LED last year than
they were in 2014 and that's at least
part of the explanation why they were
able to withstand the Russian Innovation
now in a way they didn't they were not
able to do in 2014. so so we are working
in our partnership we agree that the
NATO Summit to step up the partnership
and support for Ukraine but I urge NATO
allies to do more because it is an
urgent need to support those Partners
who are vulnerable for a Russian
aggression
thank you so much this has been a such
an important conversation about making
sure that Finland and Sweden four
members in NATO more support for Moldova
100 and I think tobias's words are
absolutely clear the to-do list is
massive but historical times require
historical decisions my last one second
question to you Secretary General
American presidents have a tradition of
writing a letter to their successor with
their words of wisdom at some point
we're going to choose your successor
what words of wisdom in 30 seconds would
you give your successor so keep Europe
and North America together and I don't
believe in Europe alone I don't believe
in North America alone I believe in
North America and Europe together and
that's NATO
amen
thank you so much thank you